hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I miss you a
point-and-click horror game and I
haven't played one of these in a long
time last time I played it was like when
I played the house which is actually
this is what yamimash said it was
comparable to I hate played and I didn't
watch him play the game so I don't know
about the game itself or whether it's
good or not but I'm gonna play it anyway
because it's been so long I remember
those times for 100% gameplay oh it's a
good sign that this is in comics and I
love this please use headphones well I
can't do that all I have is a creepy
window that I know someone is gonna
stare at me out of 1996 322 in Texas USA
a young lady named Maya found hanged in
her house the young lady have committed
suicide after two days from her husband
death in a car accident the young couple
have been married since two months and
they were happy as people said until
this time people say they hear screams
and laughs coming from the house but no
body dare go to there most of people
hear a young voice with the words I miss
you dun dun dun okay so squeak anybody
home
does anybody want to haunt oh hello well
what do we have here is that a figure
standing there I'm not sure well that's
a thing click click ok this is totally
like the house if you haven't seen me
play the house you can check in the
description below but it's really hello
it's an interesting bring back bring
back the dead but I'm not dead yet ok
what is that that can I not do to the
al-khair can't do to that I can't
believe it he is dead how could he leave
me like this why hardly seems like it's
his fault ok there anything else in here
that I need uh hello
there's something else I need in the
house like you had a clue oh really
that's how it's gonna be a clipart scary
ghostly girl popping in it be
hello yamimash what have you gotten me
in do what are you trying to do to me so
I guess I got a cycle back through the
things that I've clicked before B oh oh
no okay
yeah it totally is because I don't know
why that Nosferatu stopped flickering
with the lights over there I guess oh
it's so terrifying what in the world
okay all right what do we do now
what in the world is that the end of the
game you gonna tell me that's the end oh
here we go
I got click on the door handle I gotta
click on the knob oh well now we got
some ambiance which is awfully nice but
I'm not use I'm not used to playing
horror games without having headphones
on and also I know that my hair is royal
mess I have been inundated with work and
by that I mean I've been playing video
games it's lazy okay just a little bit
of water it's a little bit of a flash
Rooney maybe this game is also lulling
me into a false sense of security
oh hello wait no no come on I see you
well I don't see you why don't you show
me your pretty face oh oh come back here
pretty lady I did not know the ghost
girl was going to seduce me in the
bathroom here hello okay I don't give I
see you why wait a minute
yeah you better not be doing nothing
behind me I hope nothing happened while
I turned away oh oh
Nosferatu 'he's playing with the light
switch again oh I can only click on this
no I can't click on anything Oh what are
you gonna do why are the lights
flickering hello hi how's it going there
oh man it's like a much less not good
old spooky spooky scary in the darkness
I'm still here all alone it is very late
I done bad
I got very bad sorry oh I broke tit all
right just set the mood for the ghost
lady I guess okay do I just clamber into
bed and take a nap oh no I can't get out
whatever will I do come on do something
anything okay all right well what else
is it
okay that's god damn it that was the
same damn photo you threw it me before
it still got me okay
that was I miss you it wasn't exactly a
good one but you know hey it was crafted
with love and care and it also gave you
guys an excuse to watch the house and
the house - and all the point-and-click
horror games those ones are great this
one was all right not the best in the
world but I had side bets I bet some of
you were got gotten in there right in
the comments below so everyone can laugh
at you mercilessly and then remember
that they also were got gotten so thank
you again everybody so much for watching
check out all the games I mentioned in
the description below or in the
annotations over there thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
big balls big blue balls priority alert
boy you wouldn't see me again
you know those Texas